you know and this is what I've been
objecting to with regards to this
group mentality from the beginning it's
it it seems to me that it's fundamental
Danger
the fundamental danger is the
devaluation of the of the sacredness of
the individual as the primary category
you replace that by group identity you
have no idea what kind of devil you're
messing with or or maybe you do to some
degree you experienced it a bit because
you messed about with that devil and you
got tempted at 7 000 people told you you
were right it's like imagine you're a
political leader okay now imagine 30
million people tell you that you're
right and they chant that in a mob and
they do that everywhere you go if that's
what happened in Germany and then you
play to the crowd you you're that actor
you play to the crowd and you get hungry
and hungry or for that validation
and you train yourself to say anything
the crowd demands no matter how dark
right right right
and I I find it extremely worrying which
is why I speak very very loudly in the
way that I do especially online because
that's exactly what we're starting to
see online people saying whatever it
takes to get that same level of
validation and affirmation every single
time
[Music]
welcome to episode 120 of the Michaela
Peterson podcast this is an absolutely
incredible episode it's with Africa
Brooke and my dad Africa is one of the
most eloquent guests I've had on in her
interaction with my dad was
heart-wrenching she wrote The Viral
article why I'm leaving the cult of
wokeness which I've linked below Africa
Brooks spoke about what made her write
that article and the effects it had on
her life afterwards we ended up
discussing wokeness to politics religion
racism how to stop your ego from
destroying your life how to stop
narcissism from destroying your soul it
was mainly an episode between Africa and
my dad I surprised her with my dad
to be honest but I enjoyed it immensely
this is not one to miss
also I'm staying in Nashville
Nashville's awesome Franklin's amazing
too but I'm very allergic to it it's
just outside of Nashville so back to a
condo for me surrounded by cement if you
enjoy this episode hit subscribe
[Music]
Africa Brooke welcome to my podcast
thank you I'm I'm so thrilled that we're
able to do this and I think the timing
is perfect actually because I know we've
tried to do it a few times before
um but there's something about this time
specifically just the timing of this
that feels that feels very very aligned
so I'm very very happy to be here with
both of you thank you
maybe we had to cancel a few times
because my dad had to join who knows
right I I think so I think that might
have been it
okay before we get started
um one I want to read a paragraph from
the article you wrote that went viral uh
and then I'm gonna get you to introduce
yourself and then we can get started so
this is this is why I'm leaving the cult
of wokeness
I can no longer be an active participant
in any culture or movement that
encourages group think outrage on demand
fear and violence revamped segregation
fabricating history cancellations masked
as accountability self-centeredness
normalization of racism towards white
people the disempowerment of black
people masked as social justice the
constant redefining of existing language
ignoring self-responsibility constant
pathologizing oppressed versus oppressor
mentality and the prefresh I almost did
the entire thing with no errors and the
pressure to conform and comply it's
exhausting and honestly I have better
things to do with my time not to mention
it's killing us
okay
now you can do your intro
so my name is Africa Brooke and I am a
writer I'm a consultant and I'm also a
speaker there are many other things that
I do but that's the best way to kind of
encapsulate everything so my journey
into the work that I do now which is
specifically focusing on the costs and
the effects of self-sabotage and
self-censorship began about five years
ago um we could go into this later or I
can kind of just give a little bit of a
brief
um a brief summary now um it became
quite it began five years ago when I got
sober and me getting sober wasn't just a
decision that I made overnight and then
now I have five years of sobriety it was
actually a very grueling so destroying
process and I had relapsed seven times
before that between the ages of 19 to 24
and I always say that what was different
about that final time in 2016 when I was
just so physically exhausted with that
cycle is that I became curious about
what that cycle actually was I started
to get curious about human behavior
about the concept of self-sabotage which
is something that I discovered just
through research and wanting to
understand my own behavior and it's it's
what leads me to the work that I do now
where I ended up looking at my own
subjective experience but it ended up
speaking to hundreds now thousands of
people
um speaking to academics speaking to
people that were addicts speaking to
people in my family who also experience
addiction and it slowly started to
become something that felt like a
responsibility for me to give people
this information and now I don't just
focus on the self the individual I now
look at self-sabotage and
self-censorship through the lens of the
collective which is where my letter
comes from and it kind of speaks to that
okay so when is this letter from and how
many people have read this this letter
was published on January the 2nd 2021
and I had been writing it for about six
months but you know two years in the
making if you will but when I published
it it was only to a very small
newsletter of my maybe 2 000 people
and it just it just took off and by
month six it had been read by 3.5
million people and I mean it's it's not
a short lesson it's 4 000 Words which
for anyone to have read even half of
that in in the time that we're in right
now where people prefer anything that is
short and quick
um it really tells me something and now
it's been read by over 4 million people
wow okay
so before you you wrote this you said
why I'm leaving the cult of wokeness so
what were your beliefs prior to the
publication of this letter
and how they changed
that's a good question let me just sit
with that for a second what am I believe
I wouldn't even be able to sort of list
them in a very neat way
um because I thought I was a very
balanced person I had never over
identified with any kind of movement I
had never
um seen myself as a firm part of social
justice if you will I I had friends that
were part of those movements Etc but I
had never seen myself in that way but
the thing is you don't often realize
just how much
a label is impacting you until you see
yourself act in a way that you wouldn't
expect so in terms of beliefs for
example I didn't believe that all white
people were racist even though this was
common rhetoric that I was hearing and
to the point where it was just kind of
normal and expected for me to hear
people say things like that you know but
then in my mind I would say okay they
don't actually mean every white person
they're just talking about the system of
whiteness etc etc so I had been in
certain spaces long enough to kind of
understand what people quote unquote
really do mean
um so it's not as if I thought in that
way but for me the fact that
it was even normal for me to hear things
like that is what started to make me a
little bit uncomfortable
um my beliefs were still very much what
they are now but I think the issue was
that I was afraid to actually voice what
my True Values were I was afraid that if
I say actually no I don't agree with
that person who's on the left and I
actually very much agree with that
person who is on what about the right
that I shouldn't be thinking that way
that it was I was betraying the movement
in some kind of way you know that
because I'm black because I'm women
because etc etc I shouldn't be thinking
in this way so I would say my beliefs
weren't really different from what they
are now but I was
holding back from actually expressing my
True Values and my truest thoughts how
did you how do you think you found what
your true values and your true thoughts
were and and how did you come to the
realization that you weren't you know
that you were implicitly participating
in something akin to self-censorship yes
you know I think it's when I
realized that I was crossing my own
boundaries that's when I was reminded of
what my True Values were because I value
honesty even when it's uncomfortable and
that's something that I've always spoken
about publicly in in in many different
ways and talking about other things but
essentially I I believe in honesty even
when it's deeply uncomfortable but I
wasn't being honest myself maybe behind
closed doors I was maybe behind closed
doors I was listening to thinkers like
yourself Jordan who I had been told that
I shouldn't listened to you uh because
of you know certain identity markers
like the ones I've mentioned black women
Etc
um so it's when I realized that I was
crossing my own boundaries and it was
actually making me quite sick because I
think
for many people many people might
resonate but when you suppress something
long enough it has to go somewhere so if
you if you just hold it and hold it and
hold it you can get physically sick and
migraines are something that I've been
guessing since I was about 11 actually
and from about 2019 all throughout 2020
last year I was getting severe migraines
and this was when I was internally
battling with just censoring myself and
feeling like it's wrong for me to think
these things let alone Express them
publicly
um so I would say that I I was reminded
of what my values were when I realized
that I had been crossing my boundaries
okay so essentially I got a couple of
questions about that so if I got your
story right so far so you you said that
you had more or less implicitly and
perhaps somewhat explicitly accepted a
version of yourself that was in
alignment with with group identity
categorizations you said well I'm black
I'm a woman I'm young
um so I have to so the proper set of
opinions for me to have and express is
this set and then you notice that you
felt or thought at least some things
that were in contradiction to that and
then you noticed that you were afraid to
express those and then you started to
realize that
perhaps the fact that you weren't
allowed to express those or to explore
them was associated with well with
stress at least and and then with
whatever the contribution of the stress
might be to your vulnerability so
exacerbating your so and then so was it
and then did your explicit your new
explicit beliefs start to to develop as
a consequence of that and and what
changed for for you
what changed for me was a very was a
very very very specific uh moment that I
mentioned in my letter as well it was
last year when I would say this was May
May or June
um
when you know the racial Uprising in the
US was happening George Floyd
um his story the story of his killing
spread all across the world essentially
and this was a time where I found myself
feeling extremely challenged I found
myself feeling the pressure to perform
in a way that was identical to other
black people but I wasn't allowed to
actually sit back and say wait what what
actually happened what is what is the
story there was a very specific story
that I was supposed to take on board and
I was supposed to outwardly what was
that story that you were supposed to
take on board exactly right so the story
specifically that I felt I needed to
take on board was that black people were
being hunted down in the U.S and that
racial divide
um the current racial divide that we're
seeing in the U.S and bear in mind I
don't live in the U.S I'm in I'm in
London I'm in the UK I've never been to
the US my entire life I'm not uh I I
wouldn't be able to tell you the ins and
outs of of the politics of America
um
black people are being hunted down and
as a black person it is your
responsibility to speak against white
supremacy it is your responsibility to
turn to every single white person in
your life and ask them why they are not
speaking about this very specific
situation in the U.S so it was it was
along those lines but it wasn't just
happening online it was also happening
offline
um and I felt this pressure and you know
what I I'll be very honest I at the same
time as me feeling that pressure I felt
a deep sense of connection to people
that looks like me it was a very
emotional time I felt like we were all
coming together and there's this sort of
unity that I had never experienced
before yes there was a lot of anger a
lot of frustration and I think both can
be very essential ingredients depending
on the context
um but soon after that I started to feel
uncomfortable because there seemed like
there was there wasn't any room for
questioning you just had to follow what
you were being told to do you just had
to play along to the script and if you
were white you were supposed to
um apologize for all the sins of your
ancestors and the sins that you are
going to commit yourself in future
because you're white right so do you
start to wonder then maybe that
the point of the moral outrage is to
encourage the following that you were
finding psychologically objectionable
rather than to redress the hypothetical
social wrongs that were being uh that
are being manifested is that right yes
that's that's exactly it that's exactly
it and the specific incident that I'm
talking about here was born from that so
my following was pretty big at that time
I would say 50 000 or so which is still
a lot of people and I was re-sharing a
lot of
um posts that other people were sharing
as well uh about why it's important
especially if you're white to speak up
at this time etc etc and what's
interesting about this is that I've
never been someone that will just
instantly share something or say
something because I feel that I should
which is why when Michaela you asked
before what were your beliefs I I could
easily say that I feel like I've always
believed the same things but it's about
what I was actually expressing outwardly
right
um so I was sharing a lot of things
because of the emotions that I felt
because of the narrative that as a black
person this is your opportunity to stand
for something you
um re-sharing a lot of things and there
was a man who sent me a message and this
wasn't an unkind message or anything
like that when I look at it now in
retrospect he was just asking if
everything that I'm sharing and
everything that I'm saying right now
um is the best approach to take I I
believe this was a man who was familiar
with my work before so he he felt as if
there was something out of character so
he asked me if this was the best
approach to take this was a private
message and instantly it didn't even
cross my mind to have a conversation
with him privately my instant thought
which is a thought I had never in my
entire life had before was how dare you
question a black woman in that way that
was my that was my first thought I've
never I've never thought in that way
before I'm open to having conversations
difficult conversations I've been doing
it for years but in that moment because
there was just such a perfect
environment that had been created that
was my first thought so I screenshotted
that message and I posted it onto my
feed to my audience for all to see
um and of course I got exactly what I
needed in that moment and I got exactly
what my ego was looking for thousands of
people uh telling me that this man was
wrong uh people telling me that I
shouldn't have to educate anyone you
know that's kind of the common social
justice language no one is here to
educate you especially or to do unpaid
emotional labor right navigate emotional
labor especially because I fall under
certain identity markers which are seen
as more important than others you know a
black woman shouldn't have to educate
you
so that was about 20 minutes
20 very very long minutes and thousands
of people sort of swarming it was a very
very visceral and
the validation and affirmation that I
felt in that moment was like nothing I I
had experienced in a while
and
it was almost like an out of Body
Experience so maybe someone else hearing
this might think well it's just a
[ __ ] Instagram post but I was seeing
myself in a way that I had never seen
myself before
it's almost like I was hovering over
myself holding my phone seeing a flood
of this validation coming in so I
publicly shamed this man who had simply
just asked a question you know
um
and I didn't I didn't even have to deal
with it it's not it and it's really
important for me to talk about these
things in a very um in a very open and
honest way but in that moment I I
dehumanized him he wasn't he wasn't a
human being he was just that's just a
question that I received and I didn't
have to process it I asked myself why do
I feel uncomfortable is this man is this
person not owed some kind of response or
not at all he messaged me in a private
place should I not give him the respect
of doing the same no I didn't
um So within that 20 minutes I think
about six to seven thousand people
commented or liked this post and
something just felt as you know with the
same intensity that it felt validating
and affirming I just felt sick it was it
was just like that
as if I I had snapped out of something
and I know what that something was
because obviously now I know I have been
you know almost ideologically possessed
and I had no idea you know um Dad what
an appeal to narcissism you had a it's
stunning it's an I'm amazed that you
it's so interesting that you experienced
that in all its potency right the
elevation of your opinion to
unquestionable the social validation of
that extraordinarily powerful and
tempting and then to notice that it had
actually made you sick that's really
something right that is that's really
impressive yeah I don't think people are
built for the level that social media
can give you at the moment like six
thousand or seven thousand people all
agreeing with you it's really hard to
psychologically overcome that right in
in 20 minutes in 20 minutes which on
social media is it's it's two minutes
if you're sitting there and you're
holding your phone and because I'm a
very visual person sometimes I picture
this being surrounded by that amount of
people who were telling you that you've
done a great job that man he was wrong
he shouldn't have spoken to you in that
way that speaks to a part of me that
needs that a part of me that needs that
in a way that is completely unrelated to
what was actually happening in that
moment
but that moment that I felt sick I just
felt like
Africa what are you what are you doing
what what are you actually doing and I
removed the post
um and what what were you doing what
were you actually doing
what do you think it was that made you
sick
um
I was performing
I was performing I was performing and I
know performance very very well having
have gone through what I did with
alcohol and my my father when we were
growing up he was also an alcoholic we
grew up in a very very abusive home he
was physically abusive and which is
where South censorship actually came
from for me from a very young age
because when you're in such an uncertain
environment you you learn how to
navigate it pretty quickly you learn how
to censor yourself so that you can stay
safe
um so I learned how to perform from a
very very young age to perform whatever
version It's Gonna it's gonna make him
happy whatever version is going to make
him less likely to hit me or my siblings
or my mum and in that moment and I've
only said this out loud maybe twice but
in that moment
with that man that kind of
Awakening uh that very rude awakening I
felt like I was performing the version
of myself that would stop me from
getting hit or mobbed by the public
hey folks this episode is brought to you
by super speciosa superspeciosa is a
Kratom company
like so Kratom is a herb related to the
coffee plants the leaves or extracts
from the leaves
like this
have been used as a stimulant and a
sedative it works on opiate receptors in
the brain so it's been used to treat
chronic pain digestive ailments and Aid
in withdrawal from opiate dependency I
always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood before anything else diet
exercise infrared saunas avoiding
inflammatory foods which are kind of
like poison but if you're still having
trouble if you have physical pain and
you've already tried other ways to deal
with it
Kratom might be worth a shot it's great
for energy support some people will use
it as a substitute for coffee or as a
pre-workout some people use it to manage
stress and to help them relax super
speciosa has different strains
this one's red
some help you relax some give you energy
the most important part of super species
and the reason I really like them is
because their Kratom is reliable
third-party lab tested and approved
under the American Kratom association's
quality standards program in these
capsules
it's only Kratom that's the other reason
I like it kratom
in a capsule
remember because this works on opiate
receptors
it can cause addiction if you overdo it
so do your research Google everything
you take be super paranoid about what
you put in your body I wish I'd known
about something like Kratom when I was
getting off morphine for my multiple
joint Replacements it would have been
super helpful go to get superleaf.com MP
and enter code MP for 20 off if you want
to give these bad boys a shot
that's getsuperleaf.com MP code MP for
20 off enjoy the rest of the episode so
you remove the post
and then yeah
what happened afterwards what where did
this go
I removed the post and
I just retracted internally but
externally I just removed the post and I
pretended that it had never happened a
lot of my the work that I do is public a
lot of the conversations I have are
public so I kind of just continued but
behind the scenes
this is when I started to really want to
understand exactly what had happened in
that moment what had I been experiencing
for the past two years
um
and that's when my letter started taking
shape and my letter was just a journal
entry to begin with just writing it to
myself so that I could say that I'm done
I I don't want to play this game anymore
um this game is not just making me sick
but it's making all of us sick
um and writing has always been the way
that I'm able to really make sense of
how I feel without feeling like I need
to necessarily express it vocally and
I I would say that's what really saved
me from slipping into shame because
everything that had happened with that
man it was a
it could have been very easy to shame
myself or to either just pretend it
never happened which is something that I
see a lot actually
um just denial just the theme of denial
runs through everything that I'm seeing
play out in the culture I see things
like that all the time where someone
will publicly shame someone or they will
misrepresent someone and then maybe find
out that they were wrong in a very
public way as well and then they'll just
pretend that it never happened you know
and they get to move on but that person
do they get to move on you know when I
think of that man who I have reached out
to since
um he doesn't necessarily get to move on
in the same way I did because if I've
shared his handle maybe there's someone
that has me on such a pedestal that they
feel that Africa shouldn't have had to
go through this so I'm going to you know
I I don't know make sure that this man
pays or it happens all the time it
happens all the time right
um so behind the scenes that's when I
started writing this letter
do you have
I'm sure that this is going to resonate
with people this conversation do you
have suggestions for people who might be
feeling that kind of like
I know what you mean when you do
something that you're like your soul
doesn't agree with and it's like I call
it I think what I get is some sort of
existential Horror oh it's just like
yeah it's just like everywhere it's like
you're going in the wrong direction of
reality or something so if
if people are stuck in that and are
scared
how how do those people try and stop and
switch to going in the right direction
hopefully that made us some semblance of
sense right right and you know what
Michaela I wish there was a
you can imagine that I get asked that
question
hundreds of times
and I think we want a simple answer
don't we we we want just one answer that
I I don't think there's one answer
um part of it is to to try to listen to
what you say
to what you're saying and see if it
makes you feel stronger or weaker yeah
like each word is like a stepping stone
through a swamp
you know and and if it's the right word
then you step on it it feels secure and
stable compared to the territory around
it and you test that out and then you
dare to see if that's the way you think
as opposed to that Persona that you're
putting on for public adulation and
protection right that's the temptation
of the actor
so in in the movie Pinocchio when
Pinocchio is trying to stop lying and to
become a real boy he faces two major
Temptations apart from lying one is to
be a victim
and the other is to be an actor it took
me a long time to to figure out why
being an actor was a temptation
but you put your finger on it with your
description
it's to adopt a set of rules that will
well appeal to narcissistic inflation
something like that it's it's and
there's a terrible totalitarian danger
in that
terrible
yeah so yes and and that's my suspicions
are that's what you were reacting to so
viscerally that you were participating
in that and you had your reasons but
um you mentioned something that I think
maybe the three of us could discuss that
would be
would be interesting you know this idea
about all white people being racist
so so I kind of wondered about that as a
psychologist but more broadly
because maybe you could say
well are all people
racist and here's here's what I mean by
that
well we all have an in-group preference
now what that group might be you know it
might be you and the person you love
might be you and your family might be
you and your town it might be you and
your state or your country it might be
you and your race you know that who that
in group is can vary but we do have
preferences for people and we do have
in-group preferences and the coral area
that is that we have out group uh
skepticism and maybe fear and maybe
disgust and all of that and
from what I've been able to understand
anthropologically that's more or less a
human Universal you know as as different
peoples have been brought around the
world into global
Community let's say one of the things
that anthropologists have found is that
it's it's almost always the case that
any given tribe of people will use the
word that refers to human beings to
their tribe and some other word to
everyone else
and so
it's possible that that's a deep
tendency that we all have to fight
against and I mean there's part of the
reason these ideas are so compelling to
people and able to possess them the
wokeness ideas let's say to use a casual
category is that you know they contain
an element of Truth
you know
people have it in group preference
that can easily be distorted into
something that's that's quite akin to
racism I mean you even see that in
chimpanzees for example they'll go on
grading forays into neighboring
territories and if they outnumber the
males do this if they outnumber
the foreigners that they come across
they will tear them to pieces
so it's yeah yeah that was a stunning
Discovery lovely that primatologists
made Jane Goodall's team discovered that
in the 70s it was a real shock wow right
so they're trying to find all the nice
chimps yeah well they're like oh they
just rip each other to shreds whoa okay
yeah exactly well no one had had any
inkling previous to that that that human
tendency for for war you know broadly
speaking was so deep that it was even
shared by our you know closest animal
uh
relative so this is very deep so you
know the idea that racism and in group
preference all of that is something that
human beings struggle with is true and
then you say well you know you twist out
of it you say well that's particularly
true of white people because they hold
the power it's like well you know it's
an interesting proposition
but the question is well if it's true
exactly how it's true how is it true and
what's its limits and you know how does
that play out in the case of other races
or groups Asians for example right
um
um and what are the dangers of putting
the idea that way like and what makes
you so sure that that's also not true of
your group and how does power play into
that like these are all these are all
genuine questions that we should be
asking ourselves instead of
like hammering home the idea that we
have the answer to this it's like well
I'll you know you you you you said you
know you you got elevated as a black
woman in this well it's very difficult
to see that to not see that as an
exacerbation of your in-group preference
and then an exaggeration of that
implicit or explicit racism on your part
and I think that's part of what you were
rebelling against yes yes yes yes yes
and and you know what the questions that
you were just asking before those are
the exact questions that I have just
simple questions
um and it started to signal again that
something wasn't right here that I
couldn't even just ask the simplest
questions or at least felt that I
couldn't I could have but I was much
more scared of the consequences of
asking the questions than leading with
the Curiosity of getting some kind of
answer right
um
and in my letter Michaela you read this
pot out earlier about
the disempowerment of black people
that's how I started to feel extremely
disempowered you know even when people
would say things like yeah it's because
white people have all the power
according to who and in what context are
we talking about
the world you are which ones right I had
I had an experience like that
um it's not exactly like that it was
like that but for me and I was taking
Sciences because I'd switched out of
humanities because there was a lot of
you know I was taking a course on Homer
and it was Homer through the feminist
lens and I was like that's not what I
came that's not what I paid you guys for
so I switched into sciences and about
every couple months somebody would come
in and they'd say okay for all the women
in the room I know you've had you've had
a much harder time getting to where you
are than the men have
and I I was just like are you are you
telling me I'm stupid like what exactly
are you saying here and how dare you
suggest that it was just it was like
insulting and kind of a condescending
way which was the complete opposite of
whatever they were well and maybe it
wasn't the opposite of what they were
trying to do
um but yeah it's condescending and
irritating yeah well it makes me well
think about what that does in some sense
it makes your generic femininity
and your generic vulnerability
far more important than your individual
particularity
you know and this is what I've been
objecting to with regards to this
group mentality from the beginning it's
it seems to me that it's fundamental
Danger
the fundamental danger is the
devaluation of the of the sacredness of
the individual as the primary category
you replace that by group identity you
have no idea what kind of devil you're
messing with or or maybe you do to some
degree you experienced it a bit because
you messed about with that devil and you
got tempted and 7 000 people told you
you were right it's like imagine you're
a political leader okay now imagine 30
million people tell you that you're
right and they chant that in a mob and
they do that everywhere you go if that's
what happened in Germany and then you
play to the crowd you you're that actor
you play to the crowd and you get hungry
and hungry or for that validation
and you train yourself to say anything
the crowd demands no matter how dark
right right right
and I I find it extremely worrying which
is why I speak very very loudly in the
way that I do especially online because
that's exactly what we're starting to
see online people saying whatever it
takes to get that same level of
validation and affirmation every single
time and when we go back to the question
that you asked earlier of what did you
then do you after you removed that post
there were also other things that I did
um behind the scenes which is where you
come in again Jordan I thought to myself
okay so
who are some of the people that I
discarded in the past because I was told
to not because there was a conscious
decision that I made on my part what was
I told that I shouldn't read that I
shouldn't agree with that I shouldn't
listen to
um and I specifically started started
listening to speakers I I would say
actually this was more so after that
specific incident online but I had
started doing this from late 2019 just
challenging myself to sit through
conversations being had by people I
would never have listened to people that
are let's say on quote unquote the right
which is interesting because I've never
identified as being part on the left
it's assumed it's assumed because
because of all of those identity markers
and the things that I might agree with
mostly the things that I'm most aware of
it's just assumed to the point where
maybe I started to assume that about
myself which is why I had resistance to
the right
um
no Michaela go go
no no I I just liked your
that was all that was all you got it but
it's um and and also there's a cultural
aspect to this so I was born and raised
in Zimbabwe that's that's where I'm from
that's home that's still the first
language that I speak at home with my
family
um and I left that at the age of nine
I'm 20 I'm 29 now and over identifying
with the political party is just not
really culturally a thing no one even
says things you know like they're on the
left or the right or their zanopia for
MDC those are the political parties but
they're not
um it's something that I I see more of
in the west if you will like a you know
on dating apps people will have left
leftists or lefty or things things like
that they've become markers of religious
affiliation
yes yes and that's also a terrible thing
because when politics becomes religion
it's gone too far
and that's part of the danger of the
loss of religion is that you don't you
can't get rid of it it crops up
somewhere something else gets inflated
into religious dimensions and that's
when Paul and that's when when things
are you're supposed to Render unto
Caesar what are Caesars and Render unto
God what are Gods what is gods and if
you Render unto season that yesterday
great that's weird that's weird okay and
if you read yeah really if you Render
unto God
if you Render unto Caesar what is God's
then Caesar gets inflated into a god
and and and that's another danger and an
existential danger for everyone like we
we have this rational idea that we can
dispense with our religious values but
by definition our religious values are
our deepest values by definition
and you have to have deep values or
you're disintegrated and aimless
and they're going to come from somewhere
and be placed somewhere and if they slip
out of a domain of religion that set
aside specially for that
then it's easy for the political to
become inflated and that's it's we don't
want that that's that's that's not good
okay so that's not happening in Zimbabwe
so no and just to get here
oh I see it oh I see it hey second ad
what here I am again with my dinosaur
shirt I wanted to talk to you guys about
nordvpn I use vpns when I'm traveling
which I'm doing a lot did you know they
don't do Disney Plus in Serbia well they
do with nordvpn can't believe there are
areas the world that ban Disney Disney
did you also know they're putting
trigger warnings in front of some Disney
movies anyway this isn't supposed to be
about Disney or getting access to Disney
well maybe it's kind of about getting
access to Disney it's about nordvpn
nordvpn not only are they sponsoring me
which is fantastic but they do allow me
to get into Netflix and Disney wherever
I am if I'm somewhere sketchy I also can
protect myself from getting my
information stolen by using nordvpn in
said sketchy areas or if you are doing
something sketchy on the internet a vpan
is also probably what you're looking for
I also really like nordvpn because it
has the fastest VPN in the world it
doesn't slow down my internet when
streaming in different countries like
other vpns I've used nordvpn is
something I would really recommend vpns
come in handy in restaurants airports
other countries that block certain
websites and to hide your information
when you want to I have a fantastic code
for 73 off annually for them which is
pretty huge 73 off at nordvpn.com
tmpp like the Michaela Peterson podcast
code tmpp for 73 off that's nordvpn.com
tmpp code tmpp for 73 off annually enjoy
the rest of the episode so what I what I
decided to do was to just listen to
different people and I remember
listening to some of your some of your
lectures Jordan I wouldn't be able to
tell you which which one specifically
because I listen to so many but in the
beginning and this was still happening
Last Summer as well
I was sitting there just watching alone
and I remember even for a few months
feeling like I'm doing something wrong
and this was you probably were you
probably were
and this was such a bizarre feeling
because again maybe I would have
experienced this differently if I had
family identified with being on quote
unquote the left or being a feminist
I've never identified in that way or
just any of these things that would kind
of make sense for me to fully physically
reject what I'm watching right now but I
had always considered myself to be quite
quite balanced right
but it took me sitting down listening to
you amongst other people to really
realize just how sucked into these Echo
Chambers I had been because I felt as
though I was betraying the movement in
some kind of way and you know what's so
interesting when I say the movement I
wouldn't be able to tell you which one
any pick pick any then I'm betraying
some kind of bigger Collective purpose
why did you continue why did you do it
why did you continue and how did you
know that that voice wasn't the true
voice of your conscience oh yeah that's
a good question that's a good question
I knew it because that the discomfort
that I felt wasn't anything compared to
the sickness that I had felt for the
past two years actually being immersed
in those spaces and more than that
everything that not only you were saying
and that other thinkers were saying I
remember listening to Larry Elder for
example
um and feeling the very same things if
not more because I was receiving certain
information from a black man and I'd
never heard anyone speak in that kind of
way before in a very objective way
talking about certain data as to why
maybe he doesn't think there's systemic
racism in the U.S etc etc just data
driven research
and I I still felt that I couldn't
it the cognitive dissonance to just put
it very simply the cognitive dissonance
was intense but I sat with it because
I'm very familiar with discomfort I
always see my sobriety and the journey
to getting sober as the foundation that
holds me in place when I'm feeling any
kind of discomfort because I when I go
back to getting sober for example that
final eighth time I felt I felt so
uncomfortable there was nothing in that
moment there was nothing empowering
about it it wasn't this profound
decision that I made and that and now I
live a sober life it was I had no other
choice otherwise I was going to be sick
for the rest of my life yeah I think you
make you make a choice like that not in
Pride but in abject humility yes
yes yes and I see that process that I
took myself through
um
of kind of giving myself back to myself
is the way that I think of it you know
sitting through those lectures hearing
you talk
um because I I'd had an experience in
relation to you years before where I had
made a firm decision that I would never
in my life listen to anything this man
has to say
[Music]
[Laughter]
based on a three-minute clip mind you
do you remember what it was that I said
that was so profoundly irritating I mean
there's many can you tell me what can
you tell me what that was
of course you were talking about the
gender pay Gap
um and this was a this was part of a
longer interview the you know the
interview that you had with Captain
Newman and this was a clip three minute
clip you were talking about the gender
pay Gap and you were saying that you
know paraphrasing here but that the
reason for most women is because most
women are agreeable most women don't
negotiate etc etc I I believe that was
essentially essentially giving people
options as to why it could be that
there's this thing that exists or
doesn't exist and I didn't even finish
the clip I didn't even finish the three
minute clip but based on the things that
another out of context clip that I had
seen before and the way that I'd heard
your name being spoken of before in in
the context of the trans conversation
that was happening around that time 2018
right exactly
um
again I was watching this clip and it's
almost like I wasn't even listening to
what you were saying I had already
decided that I I don't like this man
because someone that I trust has told me
that I shouldn't like him so therefore
you know the decision is made why do I
even have to finish that video right and
it was just right and it was just normal
well you know we use heuristics like
that all the time you know and it's easy
to get caught up in them because well
you can't listen to everyone
and so you kind of have to make a snap
judgment about almost everyone and and
this and the default is you don't listen
because there's like seven billion
people so obviously you're not listening
to most of them so you don't need much
of an excuse and it's really easy for
that to get and I mean it's not like I
haven't experienced that like in on my
podcast you know I invite people on
Abigail schreier for example she wrote
uh I don't remember oh yeah her the name
of her most recent book but it's a
investigation into the downside of the
of the rush to make everything gender
fluid essentially and I was terrified
when when I had her on I mean I wasn't
rather yeah
irreversible damage yeah you know I want
to have Andy know on my podcast but that
also makes me nervous too and you know
because he's tired with the fascist
brush and and then you get it's guilt by
association and that might have been
part of what you were feeling so uh
those so you think well you you need a
simplifying heuristic and part of that
is well that most people aren't worth
listening to and he's definitely not
worth listening to and right and then
that can so easily become politicized
and once it is especially when the
political has become religious it's
really really hard
to overcome that yeah and so it really
is you know a lot of the things that the
radical left are pointing out are in
some sense Universal human failings
and so they have that truth about them I
mean because we could ask ourselves
um given the implicit tendency for human
beings to have a pronounced in-group
preference
and the potential we have for violence
against out-group members how do we all
address our proclivity to damn The
Foreigner okay that's a really important
question and then like I've got a good
I've got a good answer okay let me add
the one end to that and then the next
thing is well
we all have these proclivities how are
they exacerbated by by power and
privilege
right those are good questions but as
soon as we make it instantly racist well
then we can't even ask the damn
questions properly anymore so Mick sorry
my joke is over now
I'm sorry I stomped all over your timely
juice you stomped all over my tiny
little joke uh I was thinking about that
question earlier though uh if everyone
has these Tendencies which they
certainly do I've noticed that if I have
a guest on my podcast and I think my
audience is fairly open-minded but then
I'll have a guest on that and they'll
hate them and they'll be like well you
can't just
even if you don't agree with them maybe
and maybe they are wrong but like you
can't just cancel people because they
don't agree with you because you're
doing exactly the same thing that the
people you're complaining about well you
know and also maybe you're maybe your
stupid opinions aren't right they're
probably not right and like are you so
sure your life is going so much the way
you want it to go and you're such a
bloody Paragon of virtue and the light
is shining out every orifice that
everything you think and say is correct
and everyone who disabuses you of your
Notions is evil you're really so sure of
that are you
so you know you wander around and you
think God maybe I should listen to this
person because I'm such an ignorant
bastard and I'm so full of malevolence
and maybe they'll drop one thing on me
that won't make me like miserable and
doomed to hell and to drag everyone else
there too
that's yeah well
you know I I I felt something similar
when I
finally leaned into listening to you
properly because what was interesting
even after that moment in 2018 watching
that three-minute clip deciding this man
is evil I want nothing to do with him
ever again and of course I didn't think
I would ever have anything to do yeah
right
um
people in my especially people that were
not really connected to the digital
world a lot of my a lot of older men in
my life for example and women in my life
would always tell me to read your book
it's honestly I people would always say
to me Africa you will really love this
book I would have friends of mine send
me lectures I think you're really going
to like this and I I would just
completely ignore it and in my mind I'd
be thinking
what am I what am I going to find what
am I supposed to like because again I
have this idea of you built up in my
head so I'm finding it very confusing
that people that know me very well are
telling me that there's something that
I'm going to like right yeah what the
hell confusing but again for years what
the hell yes I glued it so when I
started watching your lectures late 2019
and last summer as well
in the beginning I could notice myself
listening to you and finding waiting for
a moment where I could say aha see see
right I I knew I was right and you know
what I waited I wait that moment never
came that moment never came that comes
for me right all the time
and that again so it's like there wasn't
one moment of being awake and then it's
done so many little tiny seemingly
insignificant moments where I'm just
sitting here by my sofa
just watching and listening observing
myself waiting you know for that
confirmation that I'm right and then it
never coming and then I have to deal
with that and then so again my curiosity
I finally allowed myself to be curious
again and now Jordan I can say you have
been one of the most influential people
to me for so many reasons reasons I
couldn't even mention right now
um but to be able to have the
conversations that I do now publicly
you have and I I could have never never
imagined this ever in my entire life
this is
things like this don't just happen and
the break that I can tell you this
oh no
thank you just
thank you
thank you you got him
foreign
Marvel Comics
that was something
it's really something to see yourself
portrayed you know I got accused of
being a Nazi pretty much when all this
happened it was really something because
I had been teaching students
what we're talking about today about
these temptations that you faced and how
people it as individuals get sucked into
that totalitarian hell
you know and then
so that was something for that to happen
such a reversal and then to have that
comic book come out well it was surreal
it was absolutely surreal to be
portrayed because Nazi wasn't enough
right we had to go right for the
archetype itself
so I think we've raised about four
hundred thousand dollars for charity now
on the basis of that so that was a fun
reversal but it was really shocking when
I first saw that I I just couldn't
believe it I was very ill at the time
too I thought this can't be real this
has to be Photoshop this cannot possibly
be happening it's so completely beyond
comprehension
and you know to come from the pen of one
of the foremost black intellectuals and
I I use the racial category only because
that's the categories that he's using to
operate with it
yeah so
life is really weird that this is true
right this is true as this whole
conversation illustrates
so so what have been the personal
consequences for you of writing this
letter and having It Go I mean yeah yeah
I mean have you have have you been
pilloried what's what's happened to you
um I haven't I haven't I haven't
received
and this this is something that I
don't think about so much actually
because I I prefer to just allow it to
be whatever it is right now to not
expect it or it just is but I actually
have not received any pushback
from this
and for it to have been read by over
four million people and for me to not
have been
aggressively dragged through the streets
of social media you know by my neck it's
why not why hasn't it happened
why do you think what what's what's
operating to protect you do you think
you know what I
it would be very naive of me to think
that my identity markers the ones we've
been speaking about don't have anything
to do with that I think people are more
willing to listen to
what I'm saying because of the fact that
I'm black
if I had been white for example a lot of
what I'm saying the more Universal
things that are not specific to me being
black or Zimbabwean
um they would have just been dismissed
because there are many things people
have been saying over the past years
that are just common sense they make
sense people have genuine questions but
no one will listen to it because the
first thing they will see is that you
inhabit a white body so you don't get to
speak
you know so I think people are more
willing
um
to hear what I have to say because of
that and I think it's also because I'm
not preaching to anyone I'm not telling
anyone what to do yeah
right I'm not an academic I'm not trying
to give you data and this is not about
that this is a very personal account
from someone that has been in it I'm not
righteous I'm not above you or below you
right this is just me saying hey no I'm
opting out of this game and we all get
to opt out
you know and I I think that's why it has
been received very well because I'm
speaking from the eye I'm speaking from
my own personal experience and I think
it can be very hard to
dispute that well you see there's
something interesting about that too eh
because one of the mantras of of the
left I hate to use these categories but
we're stuck with it at the moment yes
yes you know the the the uh implicit
truth of subjectivity
yes right and the thing is there's
something right about that because you
are there is a domain of knowledge
that you have privileged access to that
no one can dispute
and that domain of knowledge is
your honest representation of your
subjective experience
and that it does have the kind of power
that you just described
and so there is there's some sense in
noting that as a form of Truth
but then it the claim seems to have got
twisted and perverted in some way which
which is it kind of gets elevated
narcissistically It's like because I
have this domain where I'm
I am the only person who has access to
those experiences
then all of a sudden that gets in it
gets inflated in this political way into
a narcissistic claim that you know that
means overall my truths are as good as
any truth and they're as good as anyone
else's and there's an error there right
because there's despite the fact that
there are things that you can say that
only you can say that no one can dispute
there are all sorts of things that you
can't say that you don't know and that
are absolutely subject to dispute yes
and so it's it's it's the it's the
narcissistic inflation of the claim
Beyond its reasonable boundaries and
then your conscience I think was
operating in you to say
well where are the boundaries of this
claim like the Click the let's take the
war so to speak between black people and
the and the police in the United States
well obviously that's a problem but it's
a really really complex problem and
maybe we want to have an instant
solution to it but we don't have an
instant solution to it and so
the claim is well this is a problem and
then the next claim is well it's based
in racism and the next claim is it's
based in white supremacy it's like well
wait a second there's a problem here
and the problem with coming up with the
solution so rapidly is
well you don't know
you actually don't know this is actually
a really complicated problem and your
intuition that it's a problem is is dead
on and your intuition that
it would be reasonably more reasonable
morally to be concerned about that is
dead on but the right approach is
questioning not answering
and I think part of the reason that I've
got away with my lectures online I think
maybe and as a professor for that matter
is
I do my best to always question
and even my public lectures that on the
tour I usually think of a question that
I'm trying to answer and then when I go
out and lecture I'm I'm trying to
explore the question I'm not telling the
audience what they should think I don't
know what they should think I don't even
know what I should think and so I can
guide them through the process of
exploration and
and that that seems to well so far that
seems to be working and that's what
we're doing in this conversation and
that's partly what makes it a good
conversation you know is we're trying to
figure something out that we don't know
um yes oh I love that I love that and
yeah I I think that directly speaks to
um why my letter has
reached people in the way that it has
and it's received such a positive
reception overwhelmingly so I still
receive
hundreds of people investing me every
single day emails and
it's but you don't get the sickness from
that that you got with that other okay
so that's interesting too so how do you
know that this positive response is
incredible
um oh that's a very good question how do
I know that this has to response is
credible
it's a knowing that I don't quite have
language for because the another reality
of this is that when you have so many
eyes on you and you know that something
like this is out there there is a
discomfort that comes with it
um
but for me that discomfort is
adding to my well-being it's not taken
from my well-being so it's very it's
very difficult for me to sort of give a
neat answer to that but it's a it's a
very deep knowing and I'm sure you both
know what I mean by that and that when I
receive messages from people in all
corners of the world telling me that my
letter has freed them people sending me
voice notes crying and saying that they
you know they were
ostracized by their family members for
not supporting certain political
movements last year or not making
certain medical decisions that they
don't think were the best ones to make
etc etc because we're in a time where I
in my lifetime anyway we're more
polarized than I've ever seen before
it's it's so intense
um so the messages that I received from
real life people giving me specific
accounts of what is happening in their
lives and how coming across my words
words that I didn't even think were
going to reach many people
um and that four million means something
and it's not just a to me it's not a
vanity metric of saying four million
people I couldn't give a [ __ ] about
anything like I really don't it's about
what that represents when I have people
when I have other black people telling
me that I've given them some kind of
permission slip to think differently you
know because as black people this is
something that I have to be honest about
especially in the West were not afforded
the same level of individuality as
everyone else was sort of placed in the
oppressed category by default you know
it's almost like you have to fight for
your individuality but I say this in my
lesson but like so what what's the
weight for what is the weight of that so
I mean hypothetically right the theory
is well we're trying to help you by
defining you as oppressed
right I mean that's the theory because
we see that well even if you use racial
metrics for example there's inequality
and and so the inequality is directed at
you as a racial group so the first thing
you have to swallow is that you should
be referred to primarily by your racial
group right to to be the beneficiary of
that victim status so that's something
very Insidious it's very Insidious but
but we can give the devil is due and say
well there's some genuine concern there
too but Michaela mentioned earlier how
she felt when she was placed in the
oppressed category you know briefly in a
science class and it's like you just
said that you're in some sense burdened
with that struggling with that all the
time what's the cost of that or is that
what we're talking about continually in
this conversation that's that is what
we're talking about that is what we're
talking about and again I I see all of
these conversations quite differently
because I wasn't born and raised here in
the Western World so I have I I do have
something else to compare it to and of
course because of my geographical
location being in Zimbabwe being in
Africa where everyone around me is the
same I know I always say I
I found out that I was actually black
when I was nine years old when I came
here I didn't know that before I didn't
have to think about that I I why would I
have had to think about that now
suddenly I'm hearing black black black
you're black you're this oh you you like
you know Motley Crew but you're black
black people don't like that or you do
you like Led Zeppelin
[Music]
yes definitely yes definitely
right so now there are suddenly all of
these
pre like this list of things that I
should and shouldn't like but they're
attached to my skin color so to me a lot
of this has always just been extremely
bizarre so I've never over identified
with any of those labels I do understand
their importance I really do I really
really do
um and I I do know that because of those
identity markers I'm treated in a
certain way etc etc but I don't over
identify with them in the way that some
people wish I did which I think was the
issue of everything that I've been
experiencing
um
but yeah I I think I
just view a lot of this very differently
because
culturally it just doesn't make sense
for me to make my quote unquote
blackness
the entirety of who I am it just it it
doesn't it doesn't fit it doesn't make
it's certainly not an accomplishment of
yours right right I mean it's not
associated with anything you've done
good or bad as an active agent
and so it's it's it's it's hard for me
to see
the advantage of that kind of
identification
yeah and easy for me to see the
disadvantages
so
right
okay guys
we have to call it quits that was an
absolute honor to host both of you I am
so happy that we all got to do this uh
before we go Africa could you tell
people if they don't follow you where
they could go to follow you where you
are online of course so my only social
media at this moment in time is
Instagram you can find me at Africa
Brook with an e at the end I have a lot
of live conversations that I do a lot of
live podcasting I'm I'm just a curious
person and I I allow myself to do that
publicly with all of you so you can join
me there if you want to find out more
about my work my website is
africabrook.com
thanks guys that was that was really
cool it was a pleasure meeting you and
talking to you very nice to meet you and
you too Jordan thank you so much thank
you
[Music]